so we're here tonight at the Prince
Charles cinema for the 25th anniversary
restoration screening over will oh how
you enjoying it and what memories has it
brought back to you from the filming oh
it's great to see the film again and and
be able to share that with an audience
in a cinema environment of which you
know people have been out to do that for
25 years now and also it's lovely to see
the print restored so beautifully I mean
it looks absolutely amazing and and I
think it really does stand that well
alongside films released now basically
and now it's really been very very
lovely and it's also been nice just to
to have people's questions a bit of
answer things that you know they've
wanted to know ever since they first saw
the film many many years ago seen you on
the screen recently reunited with Val
Kilmer have we after 25 years I mean
what was that like being back together
it was amazing seeing Val again and you
know appearing with him on screen and as
you say after 25 years but we seem to
pick up exactly where we left off you
know that wasn't like we'd been apart
doing other things at all and you know
we did seriously talk about you know
willow 2 and you know Val would
certainly be up for doing something else
and so I think if if there were ever the
chance you know the momentum is behind
it now and you know the possibilities
are at their highest but but who knows
the movie industry is not one that you
can rely on in any way so we'll just
have to wait and see what would you like
to see Willow doing now if you went back
to make willow 2
what do you think you'd be up to you
know one side I'd like to think that
he's now an accomplished sorcerer but on
the other hand I like to think that he
still struggles with it a little bit and
hasn't quite got to grips with it you
know I don't see him as being now the
new high aldrin of the village in any
way you know I think he's always the
kind of the underdog and I think that's
that the beauty of the first world film
was certainly that you know he he he you
weren't sure of whether he was going to
achieve this or not and that's why the
audience roots for him you know we
always root for the underdog and you
know he was unlikely hero so so yeah I'd
like to think that he wasn't still very
adept at magic and but but nonetheless
was it was a happy man his kids might
have grown up well they will have done
by the
and but then he does still kind of nip
over to the castle and see you lower
down and from time to time and keep an
eye on man Mart again we were to see
your face properly wasn't it what was
that like for you as an actor well it
was it was fun I mean it was it was nice
not to be stuck behind rubber and and
glue and all sorts of weird animatronics
as I had been in numerous other films
before that but I think the people have
benefited the most from seeing me was
was the audience who couldn't deny that
that these these features look great on
screen especially the big screen you
know and and and as I said in the Q&A
you know the film looks beautiful it's
been digitally remastered but but I
still look good and I haven't been
remastered in any way at all I love it
we talked about willow - do you think
we'll see any more life's too short any
more guest stars in there any more
specials do you think in the future for
that
I mean I'd certainly love to do another
special it's it's really down to time
commitment from from Ricky and Stephen
to write and direct and and produce
these these shows so yeah who knows I
mean they're so busy doing other stuff
it's it's like you know they have to
like to do the special we were talking
about it a year before we did it just so
that the diaries could all line up so
though who knows I think it'd be nice to
kind of dip back into Warwick's life
every every year or so do you like to
see TV Borak up to next I mean I think
we'd like to see him be successful I
mean spit like Dell boy isn't in any
fools and horses for years and years you
want him to be that millionaire and then
when he was I don't know whether I liked
it so maybe we don't want to ever see
Warwick succeed maybe we enjoy seeing
him trying that's the that's the fun bit
isn't it for the audience enjoying
seeing someone having a go and not
always doing that well again it comes
back to that idea of the underdog that
we all like to root for you know and
that's that's human nature isn't it you
know we in this country certainly week
we kind of we build someone up to
success and then we want to knock them
down again but we enjoy we enjoy the
build-up and anymore idiots abroad as
well cos obviously that was so popular
with you and Carl oh absolutely yeah I
mean everywhere I go I get comments
about Idiot Abroad and how much people
enjoyed it I certainly enjoyed the trip
and and hanging out with Carl most of
the time so so yeah who knows I mean I
I'd love to do some more because we only
saw half of the world not even that but
I don't know whether and get Carl to
come out of his house anymore he said
he's not the he's not the best traveler
in the world I mean he's getting very
worldly now but I don't think it's
something he enjoys all the same so so
you know he's maybe I can drag him out
at the front door again soon do you
think about the return of Star Wars as
well of course we loved you in that it's
such a lovely character what would you
like to be if JJ Abrams came knocking or
calling I would like to be a Jedi I
think this time or maybe maybe a villain
actually because you know their
characters remember in films are the
baddies so you know maybe there's some
other little sit looking in a far corner
of the galaxy that nobody knew about you
see because that's them all gone isn't
it you see the end of which other jela
there's no more baddies there's got to
be someone else lurking and all I think
that could be me just living on a little
planet somewhere on my own just saw
practicing me lightsaber
action and then then then Luke Skywalker
kind of brings balance the force
trust restore the Jedi Council and the
Jedi Order and who appears daffy me
joining the dark side also of course
you've been in Doctor Who recently was a
huge thing that was amazing a big year
for Doctor Who's well what was it like
being in that cipher member back
fiftieth anniversary how did it feel
I mean being doctor he was a career
ambition for me and now I can tick that
one off and and retire happily it was
just an amazing experience I mean to be
a sturdy episode full-stop was an honor
to be in one written by Neil Gaiman and
then 2 p.m. on that feature Cyberman and
also have a really good character to
play you know he was an interesting
character I think he's he's left there's
enough mystery about him that's keeping
the fans came because you know we didn't
find out a lot about and we know he's
the Emperor but he's quite mysterious
you know what I mean and
and that shock proposal to Clara at the
end you know I'm sure that Kay was just
as quite a shock but you know he's a
lonely guy and you know being the
Emperor of the universe he could prove
very useful to the doctor in the future
couldn't he I'm thinking spinoff that's
what I'm thinking I don't think it's
been off you know the Emperor's what's
he get up to you could be a whole thing
pal series
I'm loving this idea I hope they're
listening out there the producers and
think yeah let's do that
that's it and I had the coolest outfit
as well that little boiler suit that
kind of all the gear and then they give
you such cool stuff while I was at the
beginning of the filming they said we
should have you can choose one of these
watches you say and I wear and they're
all like little you know they look like
futuristic watches basically so you get
to choose that and and it's just those
little details that make you feel like
you're really there and I every day I'd
walk onto the set and go wow I'm here
and you know I didn't have any direct
involvement with the TARDIS but I had to
go and touch it so I touch the outside I
also snuck into the inside of the TARDIS
when nobody was around just kind of
wandered around in there
pulled a few levers and stuff she didn't
get upset with me so it was cool but it
was it was a lot bigger than I thought
inside it was surprising but but yeah so
I'm a bit of a geek at heart and I was
exciting and finally of course you've
got pocket Warwick as well it's been
doing so well hasn't it what would you
see for the future for that or the more
apps for you do you think yeah I mean
pocket was fun to produce I mean it was
a with a long process to get the app out
but we'll continue to develop it as an
app and maybe to of venturing to other
areas with it with that pocket format
but yeah it's been fun people are still
downloaded loving it they'd love to run
up to me and show me their pocket
Warwick and you know I always get
disappointed when I see a pocket working
in a state of development which there's
a lot of pocket works out there be
neglected so pocket Warrick is for life
not just for Christmas I'm a chairman of
a YouTube channel called the multiverse
which is the home of saw eek
entertainment and it's a lot of great
original content on there a lot of it
I'm in but tomorrow I start shooting my
series called dwarves assemble which I'm
in and directing and producing and
shooting and editing and doing every day
it's it's pretty ambitious but it should
be a lot of fun so so yes subscribe to
the multiverse for updates and to check
out the other shows on their thing that
work thanks so much for speaking to us
cheers thank you
you